[Music]
[Applause]
luno the fastest easiest way to buy
bitcoin if you're just getting into
crypto it's the perfect place to start
hey guys welcome back to the late high
quality show powered by icon plus
capital the vc firm and sponsored by
blockfi and luno so today i have a very
interesting guest to give us a whole new
perspective a topic which i've actually
not spoken about before but before we do
um as usual i do want to let you know
that at the moment i'm giving a really
special offer on my paperback book
undressing bitcoin everybody who has the
paperback i'm actually giving away a
free version of the audio before the
audio goes live next week so of course
it's just limited time before the audio
goes live i'm giving everyone who has
the paperback free access to the
audiobook so definitely check that out i
think i've left it somewhere on my
twitter profile so you can check that
out so joining me today is writer and
journalist it is lee quinn lee how are
you hey everybody i'm doing pretty good
thanks for having me
yeah i'm so excited to chat to you we've
spoken a little bit we've come across
each other a little bit but
i don't know a lot about you i know
you're a writer i know you're a
journalist i've seen a lot of your work
but i'd love to learn more about you
before crypto
what's your background and where are you
from yeah life before crypto yeah um
so i'm originally from california i've
been a journalist for roughly a decade
so i've worked with organizations like
tech crunch the jerusalem post
la times
yada yada i've been doing this for a
while previously i was covering politics
in the middle east i lived in israel for
almost five years doing that then i
moved to new york and i was off the job
as a sex writer i worked for mike and
also a variety of publications like
salon different things teen vogue um
covering things related to gender issues
and i switched into crypto in 2017
completely by chance i was interviewing
with newsweek media group and originally
interviewing for a job in fashion tech
and they were like actually we need
someone to cover this whole blockchain
thing do you think can handle it and i
can't believe i literally said i was
like it's like a chain of blocks right
i'm sure i can figure this out um
i briefly heard about bitcoin back when
i was in israel uh in relation to dark
net markets and um
some of the things i was uh reporting on
really to sex trafficking and and sexual
abuse uh
and so when i was exposed i guess to
this different side this more social
side uh this side that has so much
potential in terms of doing good for the
world i was really fascinated and uh
it's been four years so been there ever
since
so you have done so much you mentioned
reporting in israel you mentioned sex
trafficking um
just a whole load of very different
things what would you say the most
interesting or even like the weirdest
thing you've done in your journalism
career because it can get weird oh yeah
it can get super weird um
wow that's a really good question i
don't know what the weirdest thing is
i've ever done um porn conferences are
really fun and quirky and weird but
honestly crypto conferences are equally
weird and quirky
um
did you say porn conferences what's up
yeah and conference
exactly like your crypto conference
there'll be conferences in which um
adult performers and people who work in
the industry get together they talk
about you know new uh payment tools they
talk about broadcasting tools they talk
about you know compliance issues all the
things that are relevant to their
industry
that is so fascinating
in terms of
this industry because i know you talk
about it a lot i'd love to learn a
little bit more about it you say
that they are a very um
let's just say they're sort of at the
forefront when it comes to crypto
adoption because there's a lot of issues
that they face explain that to me yeah
definitely so i'll have to confess that
actually my family is pretty religious
and conservative i came into journalism
with a very conservative perspective and
i was actually if you would probably ask
me when i was like 22 or something i
would have said porn is like bad for
women and you know always exploitive and
it was only through reporting on this
industry that i changed my opinion there
are a lot of people who are actively
choosing this who have advanced degrees
or have a lot of other opportunities and
they're doing it because it's frankly
the way they have the most freedom and
the most fun in their work
and there's a lot of ways especially
these days when people can broadcast
from home they can choose who they
record with what they record how they uh
project themselves as opposed to being
like basically an entertainer who is
controlled by a studio
um there's a lot of freedom that these
people have a lot of them uh so
certainly not everyone but society is
still i mean honestly the worst thing um
about being an adult entertainer is the
way that
banks and other institutions treat you
good luck taking anyone to court if they
treat you wrong the court will probably
not side in your favor and in fact there
are some people who might lose custody
of their kids really for doing nothing
wrong but just because there's a stigma
like what would a bank do that is wrong
so a bank can shut down their account
considering it's a reputational risk
even if what they're doing is perfectly
legal um it's the point industry is
perfectly legal industry in california
and nevada and a lot of places in the us
um but it can it's considered a
reputational risk the same way that guns
or marijuana are
so they can lose access to all their
funds they can lose all their funds they
can get blacklisted and that applies not
only to your bank account but that
applies to like your paypal your cash up
your facebook like literally anything
that can connect your government id you
can get banned from all of those things
at once even sometimes developer sites
like braintree
will ban a sexual sex worker so
it was really crazy to me to watch that
there are women who are choosing this
line of work doing it safely and
lawfully they pay taxes um and still
being treated like criminals um and
really almost hunted by the government
like anywhere they are online being
kicked off being restricted
um and i mean in addition to that they
have to deal with guys who you know
might be a stalker or weird so like
there's this dual um
safety risk that they have so because of
that um i mean honestly most of the sex
workers i talk to are so much better at
using cyberpunk tools than i ever will
be because they have to they try to
protect themselves and their family
what fascinated me from from that the
most was was i guess your change yeah
you said you come from a very
conservative
background initially you know you
thought porn was bad or evil
what was it that really changed your
mind because
i have a different opinion on porn to
you but that doesn't really matter but
i'm interested to know what changed your
mind
i guess just meeting a lot of the people
who are choosing to do it and seeing
that they are
i've like
as a journalist there's a lot of times
that that job can feel really exploitive
you know you can be forced to write
things that you don't believe in um or
you'll lose your job you can be forced
to
um interview people that you feel like
don't deserve any attention or frankly
will be harmed by the attention um
and a lot of sex workers i talk to are
exploited less in their jobs than the
journalists i know um they choose who
they sell to what they sell how often
they do it what their price is
and all these different kinds of choices
that go into making a work environment
that seems really safe and empowering
for them that's not everybody there are
certainly people like all jobs right
like not everyone who's a janitor feels
empowered about being in janitor but the
idea that like i met so many mothers and
even grandmothers frankly um and just
people who i didn't think of as like
young and impressionable who are like
making these active choices and gaining
economic freedom through that that it
just changed my mind in terms of
like people should have the right to
make those choices with their bodies if
they want to and the idea that like
no one is stopping nicki minaj from
making a music video that is basically
pornographic um but so like if you are
owned by a studio if you have like
handlers corporate handlers it's
perfectly fine for you to sell this
content but if you are an independent
woman who's choosing to do it yourself
and get all the profits you'll face all
these banking restrictions that feels to
me like an archaic uh
overhang of the idea that women don't
own their own bodies and don't have the
right to make those choices i think it's
an interesting comparison because
porn doesn't necessarily mean hard porn
it can be soft and i would certainly
agree that nicki minaj and to be honest
the rest of that kind of industry is
absolutely soft porn um 100 i'm with you
um
but just in terms of crypto then how did
you actually stumble across that
yeah so uh when i was working for so
first when i was working in israel uh
yeah some people were using this weird
bitcoin thing on darknet markets and so
i just heard about that very briefly
then when i was in new york and i was
working for a newsweek media group they
assigned me to this beat and so it was
my job to write about it all day every
day
and i was very lucky that i already had
these contacts from the porn industry
because a lot of those women will save
for their retirement or for their kids
college funds for example in bitcoin
because the bank you can't get cut off
you know you just hold it yourself um
and so from that combination of things
my work is signing it to me and having
all these contacts who had this
experience that they could share with me
i was really lucky that i was able to
really dive um head first into the
industry
so are you bitcoin only you know it's
it's such a
hot topic or do you look at the the
cryptocurrency industry as a whole you
look at the ecosystem you look at d5 and
just like you know this is the future
everything will be built on all of this
whether it's bitcoin or something else
i'm a money maximalist
i like money um so
hmm
i'm not against other cryptocurrencies
at all as they exist and frankly i've
used them i've sold nfts with my poems
inside
and
i can always use eth to buy bitcoin if
that's what i want i don't see it as
wrong or weird to use other kinds of
money if that's what people want to use
when i'm in israel i use shekels when
i'm
transacting with the ethereum community
they want to transact with me in ether
stable coins and that just opens me up
to more clients and more people i can
collaborate with um even if all i want
to hold myself is bitcoin
but from like a philosophical standpoint
right because it is quite an emotional
topic it just is it gets very
philosophical and emotional you know how
do you feel are you bitcoin only
you know or are you just using and using
the other coins just for the sake of
people wanting to buy and buy and sell
with you in those um assets
i don't feel emotionally attached to the
dollar um although i use it a lot i
don't feel emotionally attached to um
eath or to die or to any of the other
currencies that i've used
it's just like the dollar it's it's just
a a means to an end it's a means to
transact um and to gain value um i don't
feel philosophically that it's wrong to
do those things i do feel pretty
strongly about selling it to people um
especially people who might not be
educated or have access to other kinds
of resources i think we should be very
very uh
selective and careful about the way that
we talk about cryptocurrency but i don't
think there's anything morally wrong
with using it no i'm totally with you i
think it's unfortunate that there's so
much um tribalism in the space i think
everything offers interesting value and
it'd be impossible to predict in 10
years and 20 years what the market
demands and what can be built
oh yeah i think i think it's an
interesting space and i'm so excited to
see what else happens but in terms of
your career
why did you decide to then stay in
crypto you must have had a moment where
you were just like yeah this makes sense
this is the future
um
i'm just really lucky so because i had
this long history of journalism and
different kinds of topics you know
politics culture um
before i came to crypto i i understood
how hard it is to make a difference um
maybe i wrote an article that was read
by like six million people but
most of them forgot it within 10 minutes
of reading it you know or something like
that
i also did um some of the election
politics around uh trump's first
election
yeah
exactly it was pretty awful um and
although reporting in the bitcoin space
can be very difficult and very
exhausting you make a huge difference
with your readers i mean i get letters
all the time from people telling me like
oh i'm finally getting my first hardware
wallet because i read your thing and i
feel like it's not too scary for me
thank you so much or oh i didn't even
know that this was possible for me to
use it this way or um oh i gave this to
my cousin and like she was in an abusive
relationship and now she's saving
bitcoin herself to like get a lawyer and
get out or whatever these things are
like you have this like really direct
relation relationship with your
readership and that's so rewarding that
like i can't imagine wanting to cover
anything else
that makes so much sense i feel the same
i feel like everything
matters more everything means more you
know whatever it is whether you're even
on a podcast like this this conversation
has more impact than the traditional
world because you're right it's so
saturated
the connection has been very much
disjointed between you and your reader
or you and your listeners whatever it is
um but in terms of reporting on it how
how would you say reporting on crypto is
different to reporting on traditional
news you said you know trump's election
and oh my gosh 15 or something 16. yeah
something like that i think was 15.
um
wow it's it's so so so different um it's
like it combines all of these different
things i would say that the thing that
it's most similar to reporting on that i
have experience with is the
israeli-palestinian conflict and i say
that because it's extremely polarizing
everyone's going to be upset with you no
matter what you say but it's very very
hard to get to um an objective view of
facts you know one side will say one
thing one side will say a totally
different thing um and unlike the
israeli pasadena conflict where like
maybe you might go to like amnesty
international or the u.n to look at um
uh data that is supposed to be less bias
supposed to be yeah exactly supposed to
be not really but like at least there's
at least we know who those players are
right and the crypto space is so new
that like you have no idea what are
people's motives where this data is
coming from
like you would really have to be a very
uh sophisticated engineer to fact check
a lot of these articles and nobody in
journalism actually has time for like to
spend literally 24 hours fact checking a
thing making sure that code is clean
making sure that people actually own
what they say they own
so you have to figure out how to fact
check in a very different way and to
always have this mentality of
understanding like things will change
you could come up with better data you
know like 10 minutes after the article
is published and want to update in
traditional journalism updates are
really bad like you'll get criticized
from your editors about it even if
the data wasn't available before and you
just want to make it a better article uh
there's this feeling that like an update
means that you did something wrong and
so they don't want to do it um i think
with a crypto mentality you have to take
this approach of like um
releasing it to the wild becomes this
live thing and you do the best you can
to keep continually updating it with the
best data that you can in the
circumstance you have that's just a
totally different approach to fact
checking into reporting
i feel like that was when i was writing
my book everything was changing and i
was like gosh guys can the community
just stop for a second i'm trying to get
something out
yeah it's so fast oh my god it's so fast
it is so fast and
i think it's really interesting that you
know you compared it to the uh
palestinian israeli conflict because
that that resonates you know there's
never that um that objective truth
unfortunately things are moving changing
everything's a reaction of a reaction
um but fact checking is a really i'm
glad you you pulled that up because we
had the reuters uh headline um about
litecoin
so
that was interesting because
you can tell me you know
reuters they that would they they just
copy headlines of other news headlines
of other news headlines they came
through on the wire apparently and you
know they just sort of oh if
bbc for example are printing it then it
must be correct
what was your take on that why did they
mess that up so much they're supposed to
be the reputable ones we're the ones
that need to do the update right
i have so much sympathy for that stuff
um it's it's not unique to reuters
everyone in the mainstream media
business these days is aggregating
um and
when you're when you're like the lowest
level
journalist on the team like for example
i've interviewed with some of the i mean
really top names that you would consider
like okay these are the people that we
always trust they're super great and uh
when i would interview with them they'd
be like we need you to write 10 uh 10
articles a day
and okay if you're doing 10 articles a
day and a 10 hour work day and you know
let's say
it's crazy yeah 30 to 40 minutes of that
is actually getting it up on the website
loading into the cms putting a photo
putting tag words you know emailing your
boss until it's up whatever all that
administration you're telling me what
you want me to do is write
an article in 20 minutes that's not
something i could
feasibly fact check like in any stretch
of the imagination um so like just the
expectations that are put on these
little reporters are so so high and if
you don't meet them they'll just fire
you and find someone else who's eager uh
to do your job so i have so much
sympathy for people who
uh fall for uh these pranks uh on like
why are press releases that are not true
um
because
they're just given an impossible
situation
i think that's why it's really important
for people to
find media that they trust and the best
they can
and then pay for it because there's
really no way that when you're
consuming a free product that that
product is going to be made to serve you
it's just not
what is your overall opinion on the
mainstream media as somebody who has
been in crypto for four years now um you
know obviously you have that traditional
background but
it is for example we had the headline i
think of cnbc oh there's so much to talk
about my gosh okay there's inflation for
example the whole trying to make
inflation sound pretty um you know
uh just because inflation is rising that
means higher salaries well
that's misinformation number one number
two
um the way they're talking about el
salvador is really interesting um you
know they said that el salvador adopting
bitcoin would mean i think it's western
union would lose around 400 million a
year um but actually that means you're
saving exactly as opposed to you know
helping an impoverished nation save 400
million a year so what's your take
i think those headlines do their job and
if their job is to make people click
then they're effective
yeah right but that's exactly you start
to realize the incentive model is
against you as a reader as opposed to
for you and try and find new sources
that uh the essential model is to serve
you um because otherwise i mean like
nobody is shocked when you go into a
casino and you lose the house the house
always wins that's kind of what
mainstream media has become
doesn't okay but we know that that's a
gambling house mainstream media holds
itself supposedly to this beautiful
incredible standard and we are god's
truth you know we are especially the bbc
in the uk it's quite it's quite
insufferable if i'm honest um you know
and yeah they hold themselves to this
this truth like they're doing god's work
did was there something in that that put
you off working in that kind of industry
yeah totally i mean and to be fair i
still do uh sometimes pitch and work
with mainstream outlets
but yeah when i thought about wanting to
progress my career one of the reasons
that i'm working independently now and
not focusing on trying to get a staff
job somewhere like that
is because it's so annoying and
infuriating even this whole um i have
the right opinion for a reason uh for a
reason like i get paid to be so
righteous kind of attitude
you have to remember that a lot of
people got into this industry because
they want to make a difference in the
world
um they they came in with these
big idealistic visions and then they are
confronted with this capitalist
monstrosity that
just twists their ability to do anything
good um and so a lot of people still
you can do good with an article though
to be fair um i'll give an example of
like
i wrote one article
um about an educational program in
afghanistan it was a zillion years ago
that was being defunded um and suddenly
after my article was published they
found the funding to keep the school
open like media can make a huge
difference um
but
just the question of whether that's what
you actually do day to day
is it's very rare and people don't
really have that uh that connect between
the actual impact they're having on the
world day-to-day versus what their
intentions were when they came in and
tried
and do you think we're going to get
denise is going to get worse i mean at
the end of the day the whole idea behind
journalism was that it was the mediator
to tell you the truth you know someone a
source that you can rely on that's
certainly how like you said the bbc and
reuters present themselves and the rest
of american news outlets they really
present themselves as like you know
doing god's work
that's really dangerous because there
are still people that believe that so do
you think we're gonna get to a point
where people number one wake up and
realize that actually these people their
job is to have headlines yeah make crazy
headlines and get the clicks and number
two do you think we'll get to a place
where we can actually have some um
objective journalism
so there is objective journalism that
exists right um there are some amazing
bias
i mean what is bias every human being
has bias right i think the best way to
be unbiased is to acknowledge what your
biases are so that people can come in
and read it with that uh with that frame
um and there is some amazing journalism
that still exists i mean there are some
great non-profits there are some good um
and like i want to actually maybe push
back against that idea that the original
idea of journalism was to have an
objective truth at least in the united
states when we think of the colonial
newspaper history i mean like ben
franklin was running a newspaper like
they were actually for political parties
they were a way to get messages out um
promoted by a particular group
and then
like as we see the evolution of
journalism
you see okay well how do you convince
people to buy more of your paper then
you market it not as the republican
paper or the democrat paper you mark it
as the truth paper and that should
hopefully bring more people in across
party lines like there's there was not
like an original concept of like
the journalism wasn't about making the
bible it was about
talking to people before the internet or
phones existed and the best way to get
information from point a to point b was
to print it and send it out
so i think that we're seeing something
that's moving back along those lines of
understanding that journalism has an
agenda like
somebody took the time to write this up
print this up and get it in front of
your eyeballs that was expensive what do
they want out of you
when they took all this time and money
to do that right
and so i hope that us as consumers can
promote for young people and also
amongst ourselves media literacy so that
we can identify those motivations from
the media because then there could be
like great information in the thing um
but it's framed in such a way to make me
feel a certain way but if i come into it
being like oh they're trying to piss me
off okay let's take that aside is that
true is this true and then i can use
that information to benefit myself i'm
an adult i can make those choices
um the problem is when we don't realize
that we're being manipulated so just uh
i think improving education on media
literacy and like the understanding of
how that industry works is the only way
to kind of counteract uh that mass scale
manipulation that is happening
would you agree that there seems to be
um
a narrative across all media right now
that you know
inflation isn't as bad as it as we as we
think
and crypto is bad would you agree that
there seems to be that narrative yeah
that that seems to be a popular opinion
a very popular opinion
okay so why do you think that's the case
why do you think there's this
anti-crypto
narrative in across the media globally i
think
i think it has a lot more to do with the
reputation of the loudest bitcoiners
than it has to do with the technology
itself like when they hear bitcoin all
they do is associate it with like
some angry trump supporting troll who
like is going to like post stakes
everywhere and is all about guns and
actually there's nothing wrong with
supporting trump or liking stakes or
guns um but this uh association of the
asset with this like caricature
and yeah often that caricature being
like the loudest meanest person on the
internet makes people feel like it's
this like
um
it makes them think something that is
actually not true at all to the original
technology like we're all wearing pants
and a shirt
that doesn't mean that people who wear
pants and shirts do x y z thing um i
think as people are exposed to a wider
variety of people who use these tools
and for a wider variety of reasons um
that that stigma will lessen but at the
moment you're correct that stigma is
extremely intense and like literally any
time i say bitcoin people assume that
means that i'm like um want to like take
down the government and that i want to
like yell at them about running a server
in their house and like maybe grandma
doesn't need to run a server in her
house or or doesn't know how and i'm not
going to judge her for that you know
yeah but what about inflation
because inflation is clearly a problem
and you know you had the fed coming out
with oh it's transitory or maybe it's
not actually transitory um and perhaps
inflation is good you know all these
rubbish headlines which i think have
been um
recycled in the media why would they do
that when we know that this is not a
good idea we're already seeing prices
increase um
across the world i mean in the uk
inflation right now is pretty bad so
it's not an honest message
isn't it more comforting to think that
you can print more money and then that's
good than the idea that there are finite
resources and we need to figure out how
to deal with what we already have
like i feel like that's a much more
comforting message if i was going to try
and sell something to someone who
doesn't understand what the words mean i
would definitely try and sell them
something that's sweeter and goes down
easier
it makes you just it makes you really
just want to give up on
on the media and people have
you know
yeah i actually really support it um i
think some of this uh the best advice
i've ever gotten was to only consume
media deliberately and purposely like if
i'm trying to figure out what happened
in xyz place because i have a cousin
there and i want to like text her or
something and i want to know if her
internet's down because there's a
hurricane or like you know whatever it
is that i'm looking for a specific piece
of information i look for it and
literally anything else it's not made to
serve me so i'm not going to consume it
um there might be um writers that i
really like and so i'll like if they you
know write a thing and i'll be like okay
maybe i'll read that even though it's
not something i'm deliberately seeking
out just for entertainment but i think
that people should be much more
selective about how they spend their
their reading time their viewing time
and to know that everything you put in
your brain has an impact in some way so
you have to be really protective of
yourself
and that's such a great way to put it
actually um i made a tweet the other day
sort of saying how oh my gosh i turned
on the radio for a few minutes and it
felt like doomsday turned it off but
you're out and then everybody was like
oh well you need to know what's going on
in the world but you're right the only
thing i want to know is if i need a
covert test to fly if i need to be
vaccinated to fly that's all i want to
know so you're right when i want to know
that i will intentionally go and search
for it and get the information you do
have to be deliberate it's a great way
to put it
um
in terms of bitcoin then what would you
say some of the biggest challenges are
when reporting on it i know you spoke
about fact checking but is there
anything else which which you find to be
um quite a hurdle that you wouldn't
really have with traditional news
yeah there's just not a lot of great
experts to interview about bitcoin there
are a lot of people who have opinions
about bitcoin there's not a lot of
people who actually know what they're
talking about
um and it can be very difficult to get
interviews with them because they are
extremely understandably suspicious of
the media uh so even when you are a
reporter who is genuinely trying to do
the right thing you know let's say
you're on deadline you've got two hours
you're gonna write the article about
bitcoin you call up
you know 20 people who are really
involved in the space who really
understand the technology
what are the chances that even four of
them will answer you because they're
just been so conditioned that the media
is out to get them
so um getting really good interviews and
sources is a problem fact checking is
huge and difficult and also um
dealing with the the bureaucratic castle
that any publication has so you don't
only have to convince like you know your
reader that for example bitcoin mining
is not going to boil the oceans you have
to convince your editor who has a very
strong opinion about it and has the
ability to change your article uh
with your name on it right so you have
to convince him and then you have to
convince his editor above him and you
have to like really internally
fight this battle in order to
for research they haven't done for
things they don't understand they think
that they understand bitcoin and they
don't so it's both like the difficulty
of getting the information in a timely
fashion and then convincing the
publication and all the people involved
that you did get the right information
that you know what you're talking about
even if what i'm saying is contradictory
to what they believe
oh my gosh i can really relate to that i
did an article recently um for
um a women's magazine about bitcoin i
was the bitcoin expert which was all
very exciting um but basically they at
the two things went wrong and i was very
annoyed um the editors at the top
changed it and before it went live i was
like no no no you've got to keep it as i
did it otherwise i don't want this going
out so two things first thing was right
at the bottom they asked me do you think
it's a male dominated space
now my response was it is male dominated
but i don't think that's a problem x y
and z like it is obviously if you look
at the stats but i don't think it's a
problem because blah blah blah
but they they they twisted it and they
changed it to leia said this is a male
dominated space
very subtle but it changes the tone and
the entire message and that's just not
something that i would freely bring up
because it's not something i
particularly care about um and then it
portrays me in a whole new light and i
was very disappointed we got it fixed
very good but i was annoyed yeah and
then the second thing which is also
really interesting is you know you have
because we're the so-called bitcoin
expert you have big big b and little b
yeah and they'd messed it up in the
article
and i was like no you really need to
correct it because it looks like i've
messed it up because it's my words and
they wouldn't correct it
and like they wouldn't take the time to
understand why it was wrong and why it
looks bad
um
we put it out in the end but like you
know it it's just frustrating you're
right you have to get everybody on board
and you have to prove that you know what
you're talking about even though it may
not make sense to them
and you mentioned uh sometimes you can't
get the changes that you want so that's
very true and i can't even count the
amount of times that i've been uh
trolled or
people wrote me hate mail for changes
that i actually crusaded against behind
the scenes but i can't i couldn't get i
lost those you win some you lose some um
and people have a really hard time
understanding because yours is the only
name on that article
so not only uh do you have this a real
challenge in terms of getting things
right
um but
any little thing you mess up the bitcoin
community is extremely reactive crypto
community in general beyond bitcoin
extremely reactive extremely vocal and
you're just going to take heat for every
single thing
and so i totally get why a lot of
reporters are just like i don't think
it's worth that like it's it's
exhausting and it's frustrating and i
would rather avoid it than make a
mistake in public i totally understand
why some people have that approach um
but i think and i hope that you know
some people like you and me
are willing to make those mistakes in
public or willing to fight those battles
um and that we're still able to get out
high quality information to the mass
audience right because like bitcoiners
can talk to bitcoiners they'll write
these you know 20 page uh
creeds about why it's so amazing to have
hard money and that's great but that's
never going to reach a different kind of
reader that wasn't already looking for
that so it's really important to have a
wide variety of people writing a wide
variety of stories
and making a wide variety of content
about bitcoin that is all um accurate
on that note though um you know talking
about reporting on bitcoin in a
traditional standpoint what fascinates
me um and i didn't know this until laura
shin had spoken about it you probably
know what i'm about to say
is the idea that you can't hold bitcoin
if you're gonna report on bitcoin so my
first question to you is
do you you hold crypto right despite
reporting on it very very small amounts
i honestly liquidate more than i that i
hold but uh yeah
both i guess i mean part of it is just
at this point like a lot of my income is
related to the industry and so if i want
to pay rent that's usually uh in some
ways related to the income that i have
accessible
um and part of it is yeah i'm not
wanting to hold
i'm also a public figure right this is
my name in my face right here
broadcasting talking about bitcoin um so
we're very vulnerable to wrench attacks
i think it would be very dumb for
someone who is publicly putting their
name and face to bitcoin to hold an
excessive amount and be public about the
fact that they're holding excessive
amount so i try and liquidate um
whenever i can
um but
that being said i do hold some it's
really necessary for me to do things
right like i was just uh this week
trying a lightning node thing and if i
didn't already have bitcoin it would
have taken me forever to buy it and
transfer it and blah because i already
had a lightning wallet like i could
start setting up and testing this tool
um it is true that i've had editors tell
me that this makes me biased and that
means that my opinion cannot be trusted
um i also hold dollars and i don't see
anyone complaining about that so
i feel i feel like it is true like if if
like 90 of your wealth is in bitcoin
um it's going to influence your opinion
but if 90 of your wealth is in dollars
that's gonna probably influence your
opinion too and i don't see a huge
distinction although not all editors
feel that way and i think laura is very
smart that she has decided that for her
career it is more beneficial to her to
work with some of those editors who have
that opinion than it is to hold and
that's that's a choice
but laura must obviously be very
interested in crypto she must really
like it to want to cover it so much
so oh my god missing out on that kind of
opportunity just blows my mind
it's a trade-off right like you know
that you're never going to be able to
work with such and such editor and
such-and-such publication if if you hold
um so
i personally have not made that choice
and i'm okay with giving up that
opportunity cost to have like an amazing
byline in this very famous paper um but
other people uh feel differently and i
think that's that's a personal choice
yeah it really it really fascinates me
because mainly because of what you
brought up you know you hold dollars you
hold pounds 90 or maybe even 100 of of
an individual's wealth is in fiat
currency and you can still report on
that it sort of reminds me actually um
of donald trump because i keep having
this conversation people keep saying
trump is anti-bitcoin and i don't
necessarily think he is i just think
he's a fiat or he's a us dollar
maximalist
who understands you know the threat that
bitcoin has to the us dollar therefore
doesn't want any you know it doesn't
want any bitcoin so in some ways
that's like a you know a bias policy
when i mean he's obviously he's not
president everyone has bias there is no
such thing as unbiased there is only
identifying your own bias
which is the only way forward which
which is really interesting in terms of
your general perspective about bitcoin
um do you see it then as this store of
value do you see as this asset which is
helping um either impoverished people
people from different difficult um
industries like sex workers and stuff
like what is your um general perspective
on
bitcoin's use case
so at the moment it's digital money
and
just like other kinds of digital money
some people that use it are just
gambling and some people that use it use
it because they really need it they
don't have access to those local tools
otherwise i definitely do know of people
who um
all around the world not even just sex
workers you know whether you're talking
about venezuela whether you're talking
about iran whether you're talking about
south africa um people that are using
bitcoin for
really wholesome and like you know pg
reasons
totally pg family friendly reasons and i
think that's great
i've heard some really inspiring stories
of people who were able to make
empowering life choices
because they had this access to a tool
that gave them financial freedom i'm
sure if someone had dropped a million
dollars on their doorstep it would have
had a similar financial
effect right like they have the freedom
of choice at that point um but the only
way they got that freedom of choice was
through bitcoin and that's great i think
it's very very silly when people refer
to this asset as if that's the only way
people use it because that's not the
only way people use it and that's okay
it's money people do all kinds of things
with money um and i'm not trying to
moralize it and say that it's bet like
i'm morally superior for having this
kind of money versus other people who
have different kinds of money
i think that it's pretty
evident that it's a good way to save and
transact uh for a few years in the
future at least it's been around for 10
years and it seems to be very consistent
in terms of its history and pattern
i have no idea what the world is going
to look like in a hundred years because
if you'd asked someone 100 years ago
what the world would look like today
they never could have predicted facebook
they never could have predicted a lot of
the things that impact our world today
so i can't predict what bitcoin will be
worth in a hundred years i can say that
for the near future that i can see it
seems to still be a pretty good tool uh
for saving and transacting particularly
for people who don't have access to the
kinds of banking services that a
millionaire might
yeah for me it's really that end point
which i'm just in love with the way
bitcoin is completely revolutionizing um
africa
jumping to the fourth industrial
revolution of you know smart technology
and all of that but in terms of we
mentioned that 10-year gap like we said
we've spoken about there's a lot of
hostility whether it's from the
government and the infrastructure bill
which was ridiculous um you know whether
it's the mainstream media do you think
we'll get to a point where eventually um
let's call it the system we'll turn
around and have a change of opinion um
or do you think we're gonna have to
continue fighting this
i don't have a lot of optimistic
opinions there actually
yeah i think the us government has not
proven to be kind in its uh imperialist
motives
and losing the dollars supremacy
globally would not be something that
would make a lot of people in the
government happy
so i think
so what we've seen so far with bitcoin's
adoption right is like when we have
countries where it becomes more popular
um than the local fiat or not even more
than the local fiat but like even a mild
threat uh we think of the examples like
venezuela or iran the government clamped
down on that hard
and do all kinds of weird things that
are not necessarily good for the
industry
that doesn't end bitcoin it's not the
end of bitcoin it is just more difficult
for people to safely use it who aren't
like crazily smart engineers who can
build their own computer and use a ham
radio and do all these things to protect
their privacy um
i don't think the future of bitcoin in
the u.s is
a smooth ride i don't think they're just
going to be like oh well actually this
is good for everyone so we're just going
to allow it um
and because that's not the case in the
u.s it's currently the dominant world
economy second only to china or maybe
even on par with china that's going to
be bad for a lot of people um and i mean
we've seen how china
is reacting to the crypto market right
um i think that we're going to see a lot
more of that what will happen in the
future beyond that could be very
positive right like if you had asked
someone
during the french revolution
like what will happen to like the
concept of democracy there was like a
lot of bloodshed and a lot of hardship
before things got better
uh so i feel like we're in this the very
beginning now of something that's going
to get worse before it gets better
um but that being said that means it's
this incredible opportunity to play like
this unique role in history where you
can help people gain access to tools
that they had no idea existed and
opportunities that they never would have
had before
and how many people in their lives can
say that they have that opportunity to
impact so many other people's lives in a
positive way so i'm not like down about
the fact that we're in that place in
history i'm excited about the fact that
i get to play a role that actually helps
people
i think that speaks true for a lot of
society right now um it kind of is true
for the for the grand scheme of things
you know like
i'm a freedom maximalist so
we've seen a huge um clampdown on
freedom and human restrictions and i i
do think that we're about to go down a
dark path and i don't necessarily mean
that in a dark way
because i always think that there are
ways around everything and i think that
everything will be fine as long as you
associate yourself with like-minded
people and you know you're smart and you
know what you're doing i think it's fine
um but i certainly agree that we are
reaching a point we are on path to reach
a point where people will say we've had
enough you know whether it's with
inflation reaching ridiculous highs
people suddenly waking up to see their
money losing value um you know we're
talking about food shortages now we're
talking about i don't know about um in
america but in the uk we're not talking
about um
gas prices and being a very cold winter
and not being able to afford heating and
things like that i mean
okay it feels like we are on this
there's a weird path um
but on a on a brighter note what you do
a lot of other things i know that you do
poems you mentioned poems so you talked
about the poems you accept bitcoin for
them um that's really interesting i'd
love to hear more about that oh eth
actually um oh i thought it was bitcoin
uh i mean i do accept uh bitcoin for
poems okay so there's there's two
different poem things um one of which is
just like i literally write you a poem a
custom or um from my repertoire if
someone has a particular theme and and
then that just like like that's like an
email for bitcoin it's super simple um
some people prefer nfts as the format uh
so i've made a few poetry nfts in which
i mean just like through wearable
or openc people buy the nfts um i'd say
probably like i usually collaborate with
an artist on that to make the visual for
it and i think it's like six or seven
that i've sold so far really not too
many and it was actually before nfts
blew up this year so i the amount of
money i made uh selling nft poems bought
my family dinner like it was not
it was not a huge amount of money that's
pretty cool no that is so cool i mean
even if you just think about that but
that's still
insane you know you
made something you sold it and it it's a
poem i think that's really really cool
so i mean
most people i think they go into
journalism particularly if you're
writing you like to write so i've been
writing poetry since i was like a child
um and it all started i guess in in the
crypto space when i made a small poetry
chat book and i sold it uh using a
lightning node so i would send people an
invoice they would pay the note and then
i physically shipped that book to them i
very quickly realized there was more
demand for that than it made economic
sense to in terms of shipping
and printing printing is expensive paper
so that's when i started doing like
emails and nfts and other ways to
distribute it because most of my buyers
actually were international so like
international shipping on a book is a
pain but an email or an nft is pretty
easy um so
yeah i feel really blessed and lucky
about that because
it's not common for people to be able to
actually make money using poetry you
know exactly so i've been very lucky
that you know buyers around the world
who are interested in my words um have
been able to give me and sometimes
custom orders are really interesting um
really what's the weirdest order you've
had oh so the weirdest order i had oh
okay so two i guess one of which was
this guy gave me his favorite video game
and wanted me to write about smart
contracts using the characters from this
video game as a poem
demanding
right right enjoy that challenge um and
another one was there's a guy who really
likes um a particular opera it's like an
obscure swiss opera and he just can't
get enough fanfic about it he was like
write me a poem about one of the
characters from this opera so i had to
like research the opera and the
character and like he also wanted me to
do it in the style of sufi poetry so
like um ancient iranian poetry um so
yeah in this particular style about this
particular character i never met it was
such an interesting challenge and i
really enjoyed the outcome
that is so interesting i wouldn't know
where to start that's why i charge
bitcoin because it is hard
there you go yeah no i don't blame you
it sounds pretty difficult but other
than poems and nfts what else are you
working on i know you're freelancing for
several different companies right yeah
i'm freelancing and i also am starting
my own magazine it's called defeme it's
actually like a print product we're
gonna be distributed in canada in the us
um and also people can order online and
like it came from the idea if someone
came up to me and was like lee what
would happen if you were to make a tech
magazine that was particularly for women
it doesn't mean that everything we talk
about it like has to be women but like
think about like you know the colors
you're choosing the topics you're
choosing the products that you're you
know having is advertising usually when
you're writing tech media you're writing
for like uh 20 to 40 urban males like
that's just like the target audience
you're gonna make the most money from
so like what if you were just to like
not and make it for a different audience
what kind of product would you make and
i'm very grateful and absolutely
thrilled so far we've had over 400
contributors people who gave either
money or articles or art um and together
we're like as a community making this
magazine and it's just such an
interesting experiment
so what stage are you out with the
magazine
uh right now we are in the stage of
going to production so we've got a
printer we are designing and put
together all the stuff that we have
collected um we're having twitter spaces
events and other kinds of online events
for people that contributed to kind of
get together and meet each other and
talk
and yeah we're hoping to be out by later
this year and it's so crazy to say that
because like it's actually really hard
to uh print and distribute uh like media
um there's like a few monopolies i don't
know about the uk in the us there's like
four-ish companies that control all the
distribution so like if any bookstore
you go into any time you go to a grocery
store and you see something on the shelf
like all of that is owned by like four
companies and they can charge whatever
they want in order to get that shelf
space
so just like you know the internet
opened up the ability to broadcast to
everybody but then everyone gets
bombarded with the slush and print media
you just uh it's very hard to get your
foot in the door and especially you're
telling someone you want to make a
magazine that's crypto friendly they're
like what is that and why do we care um
so it's been so it's something wait so
it's something people can subscribe to
and then they can have it delivered to
their door basically yeah yeah as well
okay cool so physical and email uh
physical and there's an online component
so we will have some of the content
online but some of it will only be in
print so that's kind of like a
collectible like a pokemon card or an
nft like there are only so many that
we're going to print of every issue and
so like when you get that you get you
get the content although some of it
obviously will have like you know
twitter spaces with one of the
entrepreneurs who wrote an article or
like you know an interview on the on a
newsletter like a free online newsletter
with someone who contributed this so
like we will have some of it like
corresponding to online content but the
print thing itself we're deliberately
not doing as like an online media outlet
we're deliberately doing it that like
this is small community driven and
exclusive and collectible
it sounds amazing i think it's really
cool major congrats i'm so excited for
everything to come together for you um
but in terms of you what is your general
goal um you know there's a lot of
different things going on here you know
you have traditional media you probably
never thought you'd end up in crypto now
now you've got the magazine so what is
your goal what is my goal um yeah i want
to make a living and not feel shitty
about what i do to do it
that is the goal
as someone who worked in journalism i
did not always feel great about what i
was doing sometimes i felt really great
about what i was doing my goal is to be
able to continue to use my skills and it
doesn't only mean media that can also be
you know educational and or
organizational
but in a way that i feel like is good
for people and i find that's a lot
easier to do independently than it is on
staff although not impossible on stuff
and that will mean working with a
variety of different kinds of
organizations um and that that's the
goal
i'd love just to know before um before
we say bye i'd love to know what was it
that happened in traditional media that
you thought oh god i feel awful
reporting on this oh my god i worked on
it for like seven years so a lot a lot
of things like what like what really
made you just go i can't do this anymore
to be fair there was nothing that made
me do like i don't feel like it's you
know i don't know dealing heroin to
babies or something like it's not like
it's something that's inherently bad you
have opportunities you're good and you
have opportunity to do bad but the thing
is like the opportunity to do good is so
uh disproportionate sometimes right like
i mean
it's a million little things like
uh
one benign example is i wrote an article
about uh two women filmmakers uh it was
so pg it was so like these two women
made a movie like nothing controversial
so of course uh the editor puts a spicy
headline and a picture of two girls in
bikinis making out as the header photo
so i go out and i go up to him and i'm
like why the hell would you do this this
has nothing to do with what the article
is about
and he was like overruled
and it's like a million wait wait he
didn't even give you an explanation he
just said overruled yeah he was just
like my call
and
it's a million little things like that
every day five days a week seven years
that you just start to think like i want
to have more control over what i'm
putting out into the world because his
name is never going to appear on that
and mine does and the people who send
hate mail and the people it's not even
about hate mail you know it's about like
the people who are in the article who
come up to me they're like what happened
here lee and i
can't say anything um that's not always
the case i'm extremely lucky that some
of the articles i've gotten to work on
with mainstream outlets i feel like did
had a positive impact on readers i think
the high quality job i really benefited
from the editorial leadership you know
there's a lot of times it does work out
well but
i think being independent gives me the
ability to choose which editors treat me
that way and to choose to not work again
with people who don't uh have that same
ethical standard
i understand it's so it's so weird when
you become um so awake to all the
different biases that are in the media
and what the um what their purpose is
and what their priority is
um so yeah no i really appreciate you
sharing that it's been really
interesting to hear your perspective
obviously because you know you've spent
so much time working in that traditional
world and you still sort of do at times
so yeah that's been really great so lee
i want to thank you so much for coming
on it's been brilliant thank you so much
thanks for having me
and oh one last thing do you have any
last words where can people find you
where can people follow you yeah so i
will post
here in the comments i don't know if i
can post in the comments
can i i don't think i can
no
i'll put it in the chat and then i'll
just read it so uh following the new
magazine i'm working on on twitter
that's defam so d-e-s-f-e-m-m-e-s-mag
uh defendmag
that's uh on twitter if you can follow
me and i'm also in the comments oh
perfect thank you uh thank you very much
and in general i'm pretty googlable my
name is spelled funky so like if you
look for my sub stack it's my name you
know if you look for me on twitter my
name will help you bring it up pretty
much anything you're looking for in
terms of my work i'm pretty easy to find
perfect lee thank you so much and guys
thank you so much for watching we'll be
back next week with another amazing
guest we'll see you then
[Applause]
[Music]